hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to replaying the game I'm
actually playing this one when I should
have played it before the other one
because this is actually the second game
and I'm a big dumb dummy dumb but I
didn't know that at the time so I'm just
gonna play this you all just lost the
game that's okay but there's gonna be a
lot of fun because I know that the other
two were fantastic in every way and man
this guy's great at making games okay so
I guess we just go for it then then
replaying the game aka oh god not this
crap again yes please this crap again my
old familiar place whoop that steel bow
I still can't wait the clouds got him
pregnant
alright then all is equal in the sequel
the same the lame the game okey-dokey
then art the game this pilot
parody
pick a character Oh about this
terrifying look oh I can't pick the
scribble down terrifying looking ones
but I want it so badly
finally oh okay I'm the Mona Lisa now in
the starry night painting because that
makes sense
van Gogh head the Vinci I hope I'm right
oh look at the screamer was it also
finger oh I'm dead now along with the
rest of the Renaissance all the
surrealist art it wasn't surrealist art
I'm not I'm not an artist I have no idea
what I'm talking about
everyone ignore me oh I just made all
the art nerds mad Apocalypse 2012 the
game the Mayan the dying whoa well
that's cool and all what the hell
happened BAM oh man what in the Webley
world Oh No my organs I become it oh
well then everything will hi Oh planet
you're getting a little closer you want
to plant it X you want to you want to
back up a little bit this is gonna be
like the Powerpuff Girls
Chemical X gonna get I'm going to die
well I suppose I was already dying
repent sinners the game of the game demo
is near oh the end of the game demo was
near the full version comes out okay
Christianity the game okay no Jesus no
cliche bumper stickers
well I'm Jesus do I have to make Jesus
jump off how many people is this gonna
offend me put that on me for our sins of
course pervs the game the late hole with
David Letterman top 10 purple ants key
Clinton Letterman would Stanford and
Edwards would wait okay I guess it
doesn't matter then why yes my good sir
others have gone down to Oh behave
stupid heavy petting tricks also I chose
Letterman because all the good tigerwood
puns were taken like Tiger being a lying
cheating lying cheat oh with a cougar
okey-dokey then
Digital TV the game aka we get the
signal what TV screen turn on analog TV
oh well that's slightly spooky okay
change the channel
stock market the game okay I didn't mean
to burst your bubble oh boy going up
good going down bad in the FCC
yeah when it's the Fannie Mae don't
forget oh oh oh how do i Oh Mikey go up
oh oh I'm a skier I'm not the line I'm
the skier okay what am i doing why am i
doing it what about it what do I need to
do for yay this is fun where am I going
why am I going what am I supposed to
avoid hey yep
yeah okay so alright okay cool all right
cool okay cool all right cool oh thanks
getting a little treacherous Sox getting
more volatile okay great yeah the real
estate boom was complete bull but now
that it's bus we'll have to bear with it
ha stock market jokes always clever
calculus the game in case the sky is the
limit limit X today of the function x
equals negative infinity calculus oh
here's gravity Bay's
discontinuity now you are part of the
area beneath the curve oh the derivative
of that dude is headless that dude
mind-body dichotomy the game AKM is
imagine software with no heart okay I
wasn't done but whatever whoa whoa whoa
whoa cool I'm gonna rub my butt against
my body I guess yeah okay bye
[Music]
philosophically philosophical
philosophically tombi mind mind a open
source the game aka the free game that
anyone can edit vandalize steal
generally school lover yay we're open
source unfair fee X you're a penguin and
you're a yak I don't know want links I
can't think of a good one-liner perhaps
you can use a level editor okay subprime
mortgages crisis the game a fake a
Rothko someone who's very sassy a no.9
what's fun to time an old couple Fannie
and Freddie wanted to fund their
mismanaged EEOC's by selling their debt
to their good friend herb Ben Bernanke
yeah I believe greed and began to
money all over the housing market
inflating the artificial market boom it
was at this point Ben stumbled upon the
only way I can get this game dig Ron
Paul I mean yeah his blimp is pretty
badass but do I really have to feature
in X gynaecologist to get my game notice
anyway your game keeps the flies based
are to money easy to throw toxic
CDOs it's at the Ron Paul blimp on
the housing market make them pop grab
toxic CDOs it's and then toss them at
the blimp I think this is going over the
heads of most of my audience but hey
it's about the financial crisis of all
nine all right watch out though Ron Paul
will try to stop you by firing wrong
gold from a blimp turret molten gold
stopped you from inflating a house
against a triple-a rated toxic asset
okay cool warning I just learned that
this level is really really lacks on a
lot computers will about Philippe little
girl okay yeah about buddy that
will cause a housing bubble i ben
bernanke good line
well after what oh hey oh hey Ron Paul
let's go oh sorry that popped you didn't
know about that
let's take those toxic assets hey how
you stop Goldfine my houses I gotta get
this done we gonna pad the bottom line
if you know what I'm saying
come on me no nope hey wait ain't you
Jill wait god damnit where did I go you
son of a not letting me do
anything I'll press C to default BAM Oh
something I gotta get that guy dead
alright I gotta get the blimp down ha oh
okay okay that that worked oh I almost
got him then I'm doing good
Hey pooping money out of my butt you
think you can control me i approving
money new high score alright Oh
okay then why was their big splatter fan
up with the fad the incorporation the
inflation and the inevitable can I
please have the front page to dig now
well this got really really wordy and
intelligible education the game aka the
finals countdown alrighty then stop
hammer time steady steady steady say
okay wait this is the numbers I was
supposed to 40 damn it well alright
hitting rock bottom hard prepares me
well for my career I rock the game great
okay the situation the situation has
curdled shiite hits the fan morality of
the game AKA kill mill okay cool
warning just in cases level might lag
I'm not an old computer but first some
deontology goal rules don't kill anyone
you must prevent any one of them from
dying don't worry these rules will
contradict each other whenever you have
to deflect the oncoming trolley with
another person it won't you can't okay
now why did he spawned in the middle of
the trolley there's no one there stop
killing him what are you doing
Oh God they just keep coming for him
straight coming for him well that guy
got almost everyone holy crap jeez okay
I think the best bet is to spread them
out because they come right for them no
no no I just have to watch okay we're
fine we're not fine we're very not fine
my babies my babies don't kill my babies
too frustrating try moral relativism
with it you can handle the truth this is
getting this this this particular one is
very very very cerebral Freud the game
where's my mother gonna come into this
yeah mothers yeah yeah you want to have
sex with your mother yeah I'm fried hey
it's Freud okay np-complete the game
death of a traveling salesman buying
this Jonas root yeah - what
whoo nari sudo cool leave the generate
Widodo after one cool well that's
progress um Newman thank you I tried
real hard real hard one dimensional of
Tetris hey I got it all right cool
I'm doing it I'm a winner
I do good stuff at games lazy
minesweeper no yes I was kind of on
there kaboom a blew up anyway Anna my
urn antimatter knapsack okay which combo
of items under 17 kilograms should be
chosen to maximize the value
oh wow didn't really I guess I could
have just gone to the left and I would
have been totally fine no problem
complete what's all the big fuss about
Hamlet the game Dane went insane and
everybody got slain everyone seems to be
very dead why does that guy stabbed
through the crutch
hello everybody come with me okay done
cool cool
okay all right
okay Sarah Palin the game
got milf okay I'm Sarah Palin look at me
I can see Russia from here okay
the Rogen Rouge is hotter as an author
intelligent design the game Mount
improbable I are leavin no ER
what okay okay there we go then
chemistry the game bore in very very
clever this game is silk
so clever it's an electron cloud orbital
pun laughs god damn it cool by falling
to a lower energy level aha
because that creates light Canada the
game okay the 2010 Winter Olympics okay
sue me died from long health care line
squats she couldn't pay the huge ass tax
Mika got owned by a coalition if
someone's got something against
Canadians a epic roll the cutscene never
gonna give you up never gonna let you
down now let's take a minute just sit
right there I'll tell you how it is in
my pants so do your friends were all say
you're a but it's your fault you
were rubbing my butt I said what what in
the bus you want to do it into my pots
in my pots you want to do it in my pots
your box every single holiday a dick in
a box
your bass bass bass bass all your vase
fall back on again Chocolate Rain de
streek quickly crashing through the pain
oh yeah I got a crash sound Obama 2008
Barack Obama baby you're the best
ultimate showdown of ultimate destiny
good guys and bad guys explosions as far
as you can see only one will survive
Warner
oh it's over okay it's over then well I
hope you enjoyed about three minutes of
me singing their lead memes are made of
these cultural imperialism the game the
ultimate showdown of manifest destiny
we're a bunch of brands in America I'm a
mouse he's a clown
that's a weird double town lady
consumerism soon we won't know who's
consuming love the game Oh finally what
after my own heart this is love this is
love feel like okay if you love someone
set them free because love is blind they
accidentally fall into love realizing
love hurts atheism the game level that's
not as intelligently designed Don which
did dr. dick dog dog okay rescanning a
level and passing it off as original I'd
say that's a mod Leuven AIG bailout the
game bonus stage cool money money
before me money for me Oh fake money
that doesn't mean anything for me oh
it's all for me
oh great oh well I didn't last very long
a mere one ten thousand one thousands of
the toilet paper money being thrown at
craft companies taxes for Timmy guy limp
on time Congress manse in nature' talk
TV the game I feel I have just even know
I was fine after see someone well I
didn't even do that
Oh Star Trek the original series I never
watched that one so whoever me third
time's a charm unless there's an invader
zim movie in the making god damnit
Trekkies rises in the game oh is my game
finally time for me to shine
whoa hey whoa hey whoa hey whoa Oh God
oh well then of course the earth resolve
revolves around you
that's why egocentric and geocentric are
anagrams but seriously it's follow me
Twitter hey he's got his where he makes
great games beyond the game now wasn't
that a fun 22 minutes in 41 seconds no
how did no oh man oh wow that was a lot
of fun it was a lot more like mental
stuff in this one than was in the last
one or even in the first one but
it was a lot of fun like it made me
laugh a lot of sense there was one
segment in there that I actually had to
kind of cut out just because it was so
so so so far out there so I apologize
for that but either way someone's gonna
play it for yourself you probably will
know what I mean
when you see it so either way someone's
gonna wait here's another decade of
being what watch keyboard bloody now
that's just too sappy I know of how
about life is just a game a game without
level play listed level editors this
game is better than life anyway happy
new year and thanks for playing that's
it so thank you everybody so much for
joining me on this one check out the
game for yourself in the description
below maybe there's some Easter eggs
that I haven't found I tell you the
other games in this series through in
the description or in the elevator
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video hold down space for your beautiful
[Music]
[Laughter]